[Music]
pink showers and giant dragons sounds
like a scene from a fairy tale but in
this case it's not in the Sam Braun
district sits one of Thailand's most
unique temples what Sam Braun is a pink
shrine dedicated to the Buddhist faith
and measures 260 feet or 80 metres high
representing the age of Buddha when he
died while the temple is known for the
giant encircling dragon its meaning
remains a mystery Bhuvana Bhutto the
founder of the temple was inspired to
create the hollow dragon building during
a seven-day fasting meditation
construction took only five years
visitors can climb the stairs of the
17-story temple to touch the dragon's
beard or they can climb inside the belly
of the beast this temple is a must visit
for people looking to discover something
truly one-of-a-kind
[Music]
this small three acre island is home to
one of the most cherished sea temples in
Bali tanah lot translates to land in the
sea in the Balinese language which
perfectly describes this rock formation
and the temple that sits atop it it can
be found along the southwest coast of
Bali and is one of seven ocean temples
each of which was built with an eye line
of the next tanah lot was built around
the 16th century to honor the sea
spirits it is believed that it is
protected by sea serpents the rock base
that the temple sits on has been
reconstructed over time as the original
rock had begun crumbling into the ocean
visitors are able to access the island
via foot during low tide
however non Balinese people are not
permitted to enter the temple
this is one of the MERS visited and
photographed temples in Bali and it is
especially busy at sunrise and sunset
although if you intend to visit don't
bring a date
it is believed there is a curse on
unmarried couples who visit the temple
their relationship is doomed but this
view might just be worth the risk
this bright colourful temple located in
southern India wasn't put on earth just
to catch the eye it's also one of the
largest Hindu houses of worship
welcome to the sri ranganathaswamy
temple it is dedicated to the Hindu god
of ranganatha a reclining forum of the
Hindu deity Vishnu
but this relaxed looking God is one of
the highest levels of Hindu idols the
temple which has over six miles of walls
and over a hundred buildings is one of
the five important pilgrimage sites
along the river Kaveri for devotees of
ranganatha the temple itself is a beacon
of the uniquely South Indian Dravidian
style of architecture its temples are
adorned with pyramid shaped towers made
from sandstone soapstone or granite the
first construction on this site dates
back nearly 700 years it grew and grew
into the wonder that it is today a site
that will surely settle any pilgrims
wandering soul
in the Northwest region of Cambodia
there's a site like none other where
trees rise from rooftops and roots make
their way through walls this is top roam
a 12th century Buddhist temple that's
become one with the jungle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
made entirely of wood without a single
nail the sanctuary of truth in Pattaya
Thailand is a modern-day marvel built
using ancient carving techniques this
religious shrine has been under
construction since 1981 and it isn't
scheduled to be completed any time soon
it was commissioned by a Thai
millionaire who spent his fortune on
projects like this he wanted to keep
ancient wood building techniques alive
the building towers 375 feet and looks
out over the coast it's four wings are
dedicated to Thai Cambodian Chinese and
Indian iconography a team of 250 wood
carvers have created ornate images of
religious and philosophical significance
throughout the structure the sanctuary
of truth is considered an art
installation religious shrine and
culture monument all in one although the
creator has passed away and weren't have
an opportunity to see his celestial
masterpiece completed the work continues
according to his specific plans the
mesquita has always been a spiritual
place but has not always been occupied
by the same religion nowhere else in the
world will you find a cathedral built
inside the walls of a mosque
originally the site of a temple to the
Roman god Janus the mesquita was built
as a mosque after Cordoba came under
Moorish rule in the late 7th century
then in 1236 the city of Cordoba came
under Christian rule and the mesquita
was converted to a church four centuries
later a cathedral was constructed in its
center and it became a home for the
town's Roman Catholics while the
cathedral is an example of classic
Catholic Baroque architecture the
majority of the mosquitoes construction
is a result of the work of Islamic
architects features like 856 columns and
symmetrical arches give the illusion of
infinite space these elements are
examples of why the mesquita is
considered one of the greatest
accomplishments in Islamic architecture
in the world today it is a unesco world
heritage site over a million people
visit every year and after all its
history it is now seen as a site of
religious significance to both Catholics
and Muslims
you
to honor this mausoleum in shiraz iran
is like stepping into the holiest of
light shows
the shot Sheriff which roughly
translates to king of the light and
persian is a funerary monument and
mosque a beautiful holy place for
thousands of Muslim worshippers
the structure is made of multicolored
pieces of tile and glass and is
considered to be the third most
important pilgrimage site in Iran
initially started around 900 AD as a
burial site for an important Shia Muslim
figure the mosque continued to be
expanded and improved the decision to
adorn the mosque with its iconic
Mirrorball decoration came from Queen
toshka tune in the 14th century she
wanted the mosque to intensify any light
a thousand times over in homage to the
mosques name although meant to be a holy
shrine and important pilgrimage location
for Shia Muslims people of any faith can
marvel at the mosque's immense beauty
[Music]
one of the Circosta realistic Adele
Tasca Regis is okay yo yo se que el
yankin Yaya Satan constant a even el
segundo come on yes Omega nada por que
para ver que cuando nombre Koziol Cristo
el naschie Donnellan yah minimus and
event de Cinco de vacas - en nuestra
casa da silva de dos anos your number
sir ample salagadoola in haben Girma
your mucho
nurse to the older I get the Tula so you
love another tenemos a salary per oculus
of clusters Tanguma t stereo castle
entrada less a cupola
Ella está claro con una una cadena
tagging or halal marisa no kiribati
another
you to the Royal Society go from a
cousin named possibly can you tell me
like an Italian villa por que tiene
Mucha cyber cafe por la plancha que
tengo yo desta catedral cuando yo era
para la mano leave it - oh no no ii ii
ii really really
Ariba gostaria de menthe 11s Tecate de
queijo importantes mommy
[Music]
you
[Music]